and our series a more perfect union aims
to show that what unites us as Americans
is far greater than what divides us and
as the school year starts students are
adjusting to new surroundings and added
pressures all of which can lead to
anxiety CBS this morning Saturday
co-host Dana Jacobson introduces us to
one teacher who's working to bring the
comfort of home into the classroom Dana
good morning good morning nearly 32
percent of adolescents in the United
States suffer from anxiety according to
the National Institute of Mental Health
to help his students one teacher at
Weddell Language Academy in Charlotte
North Carolina had their parents write a
special note to their kids to read on an
especially hard day we went down to see
how this small gesture is making a big
difference anyone who remembers middle
school knows the difficulty of balancing
schoolwork peer pressure and growing
pains our kids ever mean yeah so I'm
curious what the connection was between
the characters seventh grade language
arts teacher Justin Parmenter asked his
students parents to compose handwritten
notes to help ease those anxieties by
bridging the barrier between school and
home this is an activity that helps to
bring down that barrier a little bit and
bring parents into the classroom in a
way and show the child that we
understand you you need support in a lot
of different ways what did you think
when you saw this idea of writing a note
to your child I thought it's a fun idea
but then when I saw what my wife and I
were putting down on the card and then
thinking through what impact this could
have for my daughter when she is having
a bad day and hopefully she would like
hearing from us at holidays
yes dear Marcus this card says I am so
happy for you which might seem funny on
a day that isn't the best knowing that
he was gonna get this card and that I
was gonna have the opportunity to say
something to him that I probably
wouldn't have it was just really special
to me you shined Sun and your dad and I
love you forever mom and dad xoxo
how does that make you feel I feel very
supported I think it's very thoughtful
and it it really tells me a lot about
that teacher and how he sees the kid
it's not just as a student but he sees
them as a whole the school's emphasis on
language diversity is reflected in the
notes these children received from their
parents thirteen year old Carmen
escalante's mother wrote her no in
Spanish why does that mean so much to
you sweetie why did it matter that it
was from their parents and maybe in a
different language or calling them by a
nickname I knew that at that moment when
they really needed a boost that they
would be able to hear it in their
parents voice and that it would feel
like it was you know their parents
speaking into their ear and telling them
what they needed to hear no matter what
happens today they will always love you
and be there for you my hug is waiting
for you when you get home how does that
make you feel yeah I don't cry voices
but also their parents writing remember
in this email society it's a handwritten
note now mr. Parmenter says he's
received support from all over the
country since doing this teachers from
as far away actually in the world as
India and Australia said they were
inspired to do the same in their
classrooms Gael it's a lovely idea
nothing means more to a child to know
your parents are proud of you and vice
versa yeah it's so awesome and how hard
it is and to put it in this press and to
put it in writing it's very powerful
that you're proud of you Thank You Dana
we love that story